[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 le tour de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi 13
février un événement dédié aux
professions en uniforme la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
organisée aujourd'hui une journée
d'information rendez vous tourner vers
les secteurs de la défense et de la
sécurité publique en présence notamment
de l'armée de la police et de la
gendarmerie nationale reportage l'hiver
une période dangereuse sur les routes
conduire sur des axes glissant voies
enneigées ou verglacées peut ressembler
à un véritable parcours du combattant
quel comportement et réflexes faut-il
adopter au volant nous sommes allés
glaner quelques conseils aux circuits à
jean pierre beltoise à trappes
et puis là justement trappe ou plutôt
son club de basket dont la peau michel
allard et notre portrait de la semaine
victime d'un avc en 2009 cet homme de 78
ans a pu réaliser son rêve revoir en
match son équipe de coeur dont il a été
un joueur qu entraîneur et puis deux
invités également avec moi dans ce
journal alain longet rina secrétaire
départemental de debout la france dans
les yvelines
il viendra nous parler de l'actualité du
parti sur le territoire et à l'artiste
peintre de but jean claude l'ouvrier qui
participe une nouvelle fois au salon art
capital au grand palais à paris c'est à
suivre dans cette édition et 1000 jeunes
recrutés par an en ile-de-france par la
police nationale les professions de
l'uniforme embauche je vous le disais
dans les titres la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines organisait
aujourd'hui mardi un forum d'information
événement dédié au secteur de la défense
et de la sécurité publique
une trentaine de professionnels étaient
présents sur place camille lambert et
quentin le frère
[Musique]
l'idée que tout le monde se balade sur
la scène analyser une scène de crime
relevé des empreintes loin de l'image
véhiculée par les séries télé emmanuel
montre la réalité quotidienne de la
police scientifique et de faire ce qu'on
appelle des recherches de traces
donc en général de douaouda des ailes au
niveau des vols par effraction des
petits cambriolages souvent des jeunes
sont attirés par ce qu'ils pensent qu'on
peut faire et du terrain trouvé tout de
suite des scènes assez impressionnant
tout ça va amener de la gloire et
interroger les suspects c'est ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas de notre métier
nous aujourd'hui c'est vraiment segmenté
il ya des personnes qui vont faire des
prélèvements des personnes qui vont
faire des analyses et des personnes qui
vont faire l'anc est un forum pour
découvrir et comprendre les métiers liés
à la sécurité
lycéens et collégiens se sont rendus à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines pour s'informer je suis au gsp
depuis deux ans déjà et je voulais
m'orienter plus tard pour savoir comment
faire pour être touchés professionnelle
dans l'armée on a convié une trentaine
de professionnels
on peut rencontrer aujourd'hui issus de
dix corps de métier donc on est parti
quand même du besoin de deux de ces
corps de métiers des services
pénitentiaires et la police nationale
qui
nous ont contactés pour nous faire part
de leurs difficultés de recrutement
cette année la police nationale espère
recruter 1000 jeunes sans condition de
diplôme en france plus de 3000 gardiens
de la paix et 2000 surveillante
pénitentiaire sont recherchés dans
l'actualité également pour il s'agit
d'une forme de sélection cacher une
vingtaine d'étudiants ont manifesté ce
matin devant le bâtiment des sciences de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines ils protestent contre la
nouvelle plateforme d'admission parcours
sup à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
dont l'unef les jeunes ont aussi pris la
parole lors du conseil d'administration
de l'université
un conseil qui fixait les capacités
d'accueil de chaque filière pour la
rentrée prochaine
réactions recueillies par michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas kirilow its le
plan étudiants qui en train d'être mis
en place toutes les filières qui sont en
tension c'est à dire où le nombre de
places est inférieur au nombre de
demandes est bas auront droit de
sélectionner comme elles veulent de
manière complètement arbitraire sur des
critères qu'elles décident en toute
opacité et avec le avec la le vote des
capacités d'accueil les organisent des
universités elle organise de pouvoir
mettre la sélection de passe dans les
facs en rendant leur propre filière sous
tension en diminuant le nombre de place
est donc là ya pas mal des filières où
justement le nom le plus nombre de
places il diminue où il ya moins 50
personnes dans certaines filières moins
100 dans d'autres et très peu
d'augmentation et donc nous on vient de
pro protester contre ça elle a fait son
retour la neige est tombée à nouveau cet
après midi dans les yvelines sans grande
conséquence cette fois ci rappelez vous
la semaine dernière l'épisode neigeux
puis le verglas avait causé de grosses
perturbations sur les routes conduire à
l'hiver un exercice difficile sur des
axes souvent glissant alors quel
comportement adopter au volant patrick
jacques de dixmude et mickaël millero se
sont rendus au circuit jean-pierre
beltoise à trappes
neige verglas températures glaciales
l'île de france est marquée par de
nombreuses intempéries depuis deux mois
nous allons vous donner quelques
conseils pour rouler sur la route en
toute sécurité à mes côtés stéphane
pelle et pinto stéphane est ce qu'il ya
des conseils faciles à appliquer quand
prend le volant
la première chose à faire c'est déjà de
s'assurer d'avoir une voiture en bon
état de marche avec de bons pneus de bon
éclairage qui fonctionne une bonne
visibilité du lave glace pour pouvoir
diffuser son pare brise
et de bons essuie-glaces et après j'ai
ensuite qu'ils souhaitent à l'aise c'est
ça pour vous êtes à l'aise donc enlever
ses vêtements en tout cas son blouson
pour pouvoir être à l'aise en ses
mouvements et pouvoir gérer facilement
les éventuels problèmes
bon c'est parti on y va allez on y va on
va se concentrer sur la route on regarde
loin devant soi
il est important de savoir que le regard
conditionne le geste donc plus on va
regarder loin et mieux on anticipera les
problèmes on regarde toujours l'endroit
où on veut aller
c'est vraiment essentiel on regarde
aussi des voitures qui sont devant nous
de façon à pouvoir anticiper ce qu'elles
vont faire
hélas
on reconduit c'est un petit peu derrière
du coup une petite sensation de glisse
un peu comme sur la neige voyez certains
qu'ils ont vécu les problèmes sous la
neige rails malheureusement il y en a
certains qui l'ont vécu donc il faut
vraiment vraiment c'est la chose
primordiale
on est vraiment dans un sur un contexte
un peu compliqué il faut gérer un peu
tout ce qui se passe il faut gérer le
comportement inhabituel de la voiture
donc de glisse et et tout ça c'est
vraiment des difficultés on n'a pas
l'habitude d'apprendre en auto école
voilà donc là je regarde tout de suite à
gauche pour essayer d'emmener ma voiture
là où je veux donc je passe bien
bon c'est vrai que ça va pas vite mais
faut savoir qui est la difficulté des
roulettes à l'arrière soit pas rouler
vite sous la neige fond par venez
visiter au m eur 15 km heure ouais on a
pu constater dernièrement qu'au delà de
20 km heure on était vraiment à la
limite donc vaut mieux toujours roulé en
deçà et éventuellement accéléré si
besoin
plutôt que d'avoir envie de freiner et
de ne pas pouvoir le faire par exemple
un freinage
si je roule là je suis à 10 15 km heure
si je dois freiner
voilà je fais un freinage progressif de
façon à ne pas bloquer les roues alors
merci stéphane pour tous ses conseils
alors pour synthétiser
il faut être certain que sa voiture soit
dans un bon état de fonctionnement
s'assurer de bien mettre sa ceinture de
sécurité
regarder loin devant soi pour pour
anticiper tout ce qui peut se passer
ne pas utiliser son smartphone post est
bien concentré et avoir une conduite
douce des freinages doux pour ne pas
bloquer les roues et ne pas glisser
merci beaucoup stéphane et bon courage à
tous ceux qui sont sur la route et on
remercie à le circuit jean-pierre
beltoise de nous avoir accueillis pour
cet exercice
on ouvre à présent une page politique
avec cette visite hier lundi delfina
génie stéphan s'est rendu dans les
yvelines en compagnie du député jean
noël barrot la secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'économie et des
finances est d'abord allé à l'iut de
vélizy rencontre avec les startups oled
comme est géré au lift le déplacement
s'est poursuivi ensuite à la cci
versailles yvelines dialogue avec la
communauté des financeurs du territoire
le but c'est d'échanger sur la situation
des entreprises et leurs conditions de
financement le département un excellent
laboratoire pour jean-noël barrot
écoutez le au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
oui je pense que c'est un bon
laboratoire et qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à apprendre comme je le disais
notamment sur la question de la
conversion la recherche la nature de la
recherche publique dans les entreprises
innovantes fois que là il ya un gros
sujet et puis on a aussi les grandes
entreprises qui sont très impliqués dans
la question de l'association de leurs
salariés
bien à la vie de l'entreprise et à la
participation des entreprises donc on à
laurent legendre qui à airbus a
travaillé sur ces sujets là et donc je
pense que tout ça est très intéressant
et delphine génie stéphan qui va se
servir de ces échanges pour rédiger le
projet de loi du pacte le plan d'action
pour la croissance et la transformation
des entreprises
politique toujours avec un invité qui
m'a rejoint en plateau c'est alain
longet rynnas bon soir en soir grégory
vous êtes le secrétaire départemental de
debout la france dans les yvelines on va
parler de l'actualité de votre parti
alors qu'un un conseil national s'est
tenu au mois de février plusieurs
d'ailleurs décisions ont été prises lors
de ce conseil déjà localement dans les
yvelines début d'année 2010 8 animé avec
une nouvelle équipe sur sur le
territoire et et vous venez d'ailleurs
la présenter cette année l'équipe tout à
fait donc l'équipe évinoise en fait est
tout à fait représentative de ce qui est
devenu le parti debout la france
aujourd'hui c'est à dire des gens qui
historiquement ont soutenu à l'action de
nicolas de poing dupont aignan quand il
a fondé debout la république et ensuite
toute une vague de nouveaux adhérents
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de nouveaux
adhérents qui rejoint actuellement le
parti pour qui vit qui viennent grossir
les rangs et qui viennent s'impliquer
pour mettre en avant défendre les idées
qui sont défendues par debout la france
donc donc des anciens comme sylvia
cantaluppi qui est notre présidente
d'honneur au niveau de la fédération des
yvelines et moi même on va dire
représentants de cette nouvelle vague
je n'avais jamais fait de politique
avant de
de rejoindre debout la france mais
devant ce qui s'est passé l'élection de
d'emmanuel macron et toutes les
conséquences qu'on est en train de
commencer à mesurer aujourd'hui
donc j'ai décidé de m'engager
il s'est trouvé que nicolas dupont
aignan a bien voulu me confier les
destinées
mais justement 2017 pour debout la
france si on revient sur les
législatives ya le parti a obtenu 1,45 %
au premier tour des législatives en juin
dernier dans l'est dans les yvelines
le parti encore peu représenté dans le
département quelle stratégie là vous
allez mettre en place sur cette année
quelle action sur sur ce territoire des
yvelines alors déjà ce qu'il faut
également rappeler c'est qu'il ya eu une
élection législative partielle qui nous
a donné à 4 3% et c'est tout à fait
représentatif de l'évolution qu'on
connaît les premiers sondages également
pour les échéances européennes ne donne
à 6% ce qui enverrait cinq ou six
députés européens
debout la france au conseil européen
rappelait les européennes ça en 2010 là
vous voyez tout à fait l'an prochain
donc l'idée aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya eu tout un plan
d'action qui a été mis en place qui
était qui ont été en partie présenté au
conseil national est donc lié l'idée
pour l'équipe des yvelines c'est de
relayer cette action de faire connaître
notre programme parce qu'on veut être
aussi et surtout un parti de
propositions et surtout pas se cantonner
à simplement critiquer l'action actuelle
du gouvernement
on pense que les choses peuvent être
bien fait au bénéfice du plus grand
nombre
en procédant différemment que ce soit à
l'échelon européen ou à l'échelon
national au niveau national justement le
président du parti debout la france
nicolas dupont aignan a requis on
rappelle 4,70 % des voix au premier tour
des présidentielles puis d'un million de
français ont mis un bulletin nicolas
dupont-aignan dans les yeux en une année
2010 est finalement on peut dire
chamboule-tout sur le niveau politique
avec l'élection d' emmanuel macron
qu'est ce qui a été dit lors du conseil
national est ce que l'idée c'est de
profiter de cet élan de renouveau des
pratiques politiques incarner une
opposition crédible face au gouvernement
absolument alors pour ça
on est nicolas dupont aignan a lancé une
association qui s'appelle les amoureux
de la france avec jean frédéric poisson
tout à fait viennent également emmanuel
reynard également monsieur duick un qui
était un ancien député
les républicains qui est encore députés
juste avant les ailes et les élections
qui viennent de se dérouler maire de
brienne le château donc une figure
politique connue est importante et qui a
même rejoint debout la france
en entrant lui-même au conseil national
chargé des questions de défense
on entend souvent un mort venir c'est
dans beaucoup de bouche c'est le mot de
patriotes notamment celle de nicolas
dupont aignan qui a dit chez nos
confrères d'rtl récemment une union des
patriotes et des républicains est la
seule alternative possible
ça veut dire quoi c'est une union de la
droite entre tous ceux qui se réclament
patriotes normalement tous ceux qui ceux
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans une
europe fédérale mais qui se
reconnaissent dans une belle europe des
nations souveraines
là on constate que ce qui fonctionne le
mieux au sein de l'union européenne
combat dans sa forme actuelle
c'est justement ce sont les projets qui
sont menés par un nombre réduit de deux
nations et est très concret donc nous ce
qu'on veut c'est prolonger sa est
proposé lors des prochaines élections
effectivement grâce en s'appuyant sur
alors non pas un rassemblement
simplement des forces de droite mais
tout simplement des amoureux de la
france ce que ça peut aller vers une
union par exemple avec florian philippot
qui a lancé son parti des patriotes son
mouvement des patriotes
pourquoi pas c'est pas du tout exclu par
contre y aura pas d'alliance à deux on
souhaite dans ce cas-là rassembler le
plus largement possible et il y aura
dans ce cas là des représentants des
républicains ou des dés républiques
représentant du front national il n'y
aura pas d'alliance à 2 soit d'un côté
soit de l'autre parce que d'un côté on
aurait des républicains qui penseraient
qui en fait debout la france pourrait
devenir lui di2 de la droite qui n'est
absolument pas le cas et une alliance
uniquement avec le front national de
marine le pen
je précise aussi que jamais été question
d'une alliance avec le front national de
jean marie le pen donc le front national
de marine le pen
ça serait pas forcément une bonne chose
pour pour debout la france et au
quelqu'un on cherchera à rassembler au
niveau des citoyens donc le plus
largement possible autour d'un projet
beau projet pour une belle robe merci à
l'allongé rynnas d'avoir été avec nous a
écoutés merci beaucoup et je rappelle
vous êtes secrétaire du parti debout la
france dans les yvelines merci d'avoir
été avec nous autre sujet à présent
c'était le dernier jour hier de la
chasse sur les 680 hectares de la forêt
de port royal ce lundi une battue
encadrés par l'office national des
forêts qui permet de réguler les
populations de sangliers et de
chevreuils s'est tenu nicolas landry est
allé suivre la traque des chasseurs
durant la matinée attention certaines
images de ce sujet peuvent heurter la
sensibilité de certains téléspectateurs
il est 10h à la maison à maria do coeur
de la forêt de port royal
une trentaine de chasseurs écoutent les
consignes de sécurité des déplacements
vécu même sur la propriété se font avec
les armes dans les housses tout démonter
gilet orange comme d'hab' el mirador des
outils utilisés pour la sécurité de tous
on prend nos mirador parce que vu que
c'est une forêt périurbaine
on a obligation d'installer des miradors
donc chaque post et sera sur un mirador
après l'installation des miradors la
chasse peut commencer
un quota réglementaire de 13 chevreuil
est fixé pour le sanglier c'est illimité
les chasseurs sur les miradors attendent
les animaux les autres vont les traquer
ensuite on va traquer tous ensemble on
va sera aligné sur le chemin et on va
repousser directement sur les poster qui
sont là à peu près 1 km la regarde un
chevreuil qui va sauter la ligne voilà
ça permet la halle annonce ça permet de
prévenir pour les poster qui lie à un
chevreuil qui est sorti de la traque
regarde sangliers 6e sangliers tentent
de se cacher d'autres tracker ont repéré
une compagnie la chasse se poursuit dans
une autre partie de la forêt et cette
fois-ci l'annnonce du sanglier mort
retentir le surveiller à charge et quand
même
les chiens et donc les deux tracker vu
que je surveillais et théo ferme olivier
avec laurent bon ben ils ont tiré là
dans l'hérault s'ils étaient acculés
avec un premier sanglier abattu la
chasse n'est pas terminée la battue
continue tout au long de la journée et
culture à présent 2000 artistes qui
exposent pendant cinq jours la 12e
édition du salon art capital se tient à
partir de demain
c'est sous la verrière du grand palais à
paris et c'est jusqu'à dimanche on
pourra y retrouver des talents confirmés
ou en devenir notamment un yvelinois
originaire de buc ces gens que l'ouvrier
bonsoir monsieur artiste peintre donc et
vous êtes également un ancien sportif de
haut niveau on aura l'occasion d'en
parler dans cette interview
alors vous exposerez art capital un
tableau portrait de dorine bourneton une
véritable battante c'est la première
femme handicapée à devenir pilote de
voltige déjà sur sur le salon c'est
votre quatrième participation aux
besoins pourquoi faut-il y être rares
capitales
tout simplement parce que c'est l'une
des plus grosses expositions et puis
c'est c'était un rêve
j'y allais souvent et
j'ai toujours envie de participer et
puis voilà je fais mes rêves
voilà tout simplement alors le programme
sur ces cinq jours on imagine exposés se
faire connaître c'est aussi peut-être
échanger avec les autres artistes
absolument absolument
alors votre tableau exposé c'est un
portrait the lady de dorine bourneton
alors cette femme est devenue
paraplégique après un accident d'avion
en 1991 seule survivante à 16 ans de ce
crash
ça ne m'empêchera pas quatre ans plus
tard de passer son brevet de pilotage
aujourd'hui lé pilote de voltige
pourquoi avoir choisi dorine bourneton
pour ce portrait est tout simplement je
les rencontre et en 2016 et la promotion
de son livre en fait j'avais été invité
par une dame qui s'appelle mathilde et
nanteuil et
en fait il m'a proposé de venir la voir
et lui dire m'a dit qu'il fallait
absolument que je l'aide
en fait j'ai discuté avec elle et puis
on avait plein de choses en commun entre
autres le défi et puis spontanément je
lui ai dit écoute dorine ça dis pas que
je t'explose en 2018 au grand palais
j'ai dit je sais pas si j'y arriverais
mais on peut toujours essayer
voilà qu'est ce qui vous a touché dans
son histoire à écouter
une sportive comme ça paraplégique
sachant que le handicap c'est c'est
vraiment très difficile de se déplacer
et à beaucoup de choses qui sont
difficiles pour eux quoi j'ai relu
absolue atelier à d'autres personnes de
mieux vivre à la voix oui j'ai voulu
l'aider absolument quoi ils placent
homme se faisait énormément plaisir
très bon sujet alors sur le tableau on
voit dorine bourneton sur la composition
de ce tableau devant son avion on
distingue également la patrouille de
france en arrière plan elle est avec la
patrouille de france
sinon quelle idée derrière voilà comment
vous avez constitué peint ce tableau
bah écoutez j'ai discuté avec elle parce
que je les ai vu quelques temps après
les croyez pas trop que j'allais revenir
poids et puis m'a dit bon écoute la
patrouille de france
il ya des personnes que j'aimerais bien
voir entre eux et adrienne bolland
traverser la cordillère des andes il ya
vraiment de large et où brigitte rey
blain falco ce qui l'a énormément aidé
pour son combat pour les handicapés
c'est ces deux visages qu'on voit
également sur les trois les trois
visages à trois saisons en plus de celui
d'adam douala vol fatal à la voilà sur
la réalisation du tableau combien de
temps ça vous à ça vous a pris de maux à
peu près de moi même voulons réaliser
voilà ce tableau est est ce que vous
comptez lui en faire cadeau peut-être
sur ça et c'est une évidence c'est une
fit alors portrait de femme qui n'est
pas votre votre vous est pas on est pas
je vais y arriver à votre galon à décès
lors du dernière capitale
vous aviez fait le portrait de manon
valentino champion de bmx qui a
participé aux derniers jo de rio en 2016
elle aurait pu ne pas y participer parce
qu'elle a eu une grosse blessure juste
juste avant ces gosses et ces femmes
battantes ça vous inspire
manon pourquoi parce qu'en fait j'ai
tout simplement je voulais traiter de la
course et puis je voulais une fan
absolument parce que c'est un monde
d'hommes et manon effectivement à devait
pas faire les jeux olympiques j'ai dit
c'est pas très grave et en plus elle
était très jolie et en plus elle est
arrivée en finale des jeux olympiques
c'était super pour moi moi c'est la
représentation du bmx au grand palais
pour moi c'est voilà j'aurais explosé
quelqu'un qui fait du bmx au grand
palais pour moi c'est génial connard
d'ailleurs vous êtes vous
on l'a dit en début d'entretien un
ancien athlète de bmx de très haut
niveau j'ai un pion de france 87
vice-champion d'europe en 89 et l'on
passe du du bmx allard sa ceinture mais
pour moi c'était simple pourquoi parce
que les mêmes sensations
le défi c'est dangereux
psychologiquement et à la fin on
s'expose
et voilà c'est ça c'est exactement
pareil les mêmes sensations que j'ai
retrouvées pour moi c'est génial quand
je peux plus en faire donc voilà
maintenant c'est la peinture et sur
votre style quand on voit les deux
tableaux sans la pop art réaliste on
sait qu'une aspiration un peu urbaine
aussi dans cette table oui oui tout à
fait et essayer de faire des choses un
petit peu en bas dir noodle et
bah écoutez moi je peux partir dans tous
les sens c'est pas très grave jean
pierre camatte est en fait voilà et vous
exposerez donc je le rappelle jean paul
au brier un portrait dorine bourneton au
12e salon art capital merci d'avoir été
avec nous le salon qui se tient de
demain à dimanche au grand palais à
paris et pour plus d'informations sur
cet événement vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran on termine ce journal par
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire dans ce
dans cette édition le portrait de la
rédaction est consacrée à michel allard
un pionnier du club de basket ball de
trappes il y a joué puis entraîné samedi
soir l'homme a assisté au match 2 le fc
trappes face au havre un rêve réalisé
alors que son état de santé s'était
dégradé une sortie randy rendue possible
par l'association manic oise éducatives
et culturelles rencontre signée par
nicolas landry
il n'a pas pu s'en empêcher à près de 80
ans michel allard a tenté quelques tirs
au panier
cet ancien joueur et dirigeant du club
de trappes la verrière est venu voir
jouer les seniors de nationale 3
l'occasion d'évoquer ses souvenirs
d'entraîneur
quelques photos peut-être que vous êtes
dessus et indiens et que je rappelle
qu'elle voudrait sa carrière rachid la
caméra rachid et nous a trahis ils
devancent
abboud et il a depuis son avc en 2009 il
n'avait plus revu un match 2 le fc
trappes un manque pour ce passionné qui
a marqué ses premiers paniers à l'âge de
8 ans sacré que j'ai rendu ma famille
quand la rencontre débute michel allard
n'hésite pas à commenter les actions son
passé d'entraîneur ressurgi sur le bord
du terrain
crémer plus que sept je trouve qu'on
rencontre sur le banc de touche à ses
côtés l'association manic oise
éducatives et culturelles a organisé
cette sortie et surtout sa petite fille
alexandra ça me fait très plaisir
surtout que ces voix là c'est quelque
chose qui voulait faire de viande
un moment dont moi ça ne me plaisait de
l'accompagner ce soir pour ce beau match
en fait quand j'étais plus jeune je
l'accompagné à ces matchs de basket
donc je regardais donc j'ai toujours
baigné dedans accompagné des seniors
dans leurs rêves et leurs envies par
l'intermédiaire de
deux jeunes adultes d'adolescents de la
commune de magny ou autres lors de cette
rencontre trappe s'inclinent finalement
sur le score de 64 à 88 face au havre et
le passionné dresse son bilan par
rapport à cette défaite
il y rester le même personnage à savoir
très impliqué pas toujours modérée dans
ses appréciations euros bah faudrait
qu'ils reviennent à prochaine fois et en
fera bien on fera mieux on gagnera au
moins et michel allard compte revenir
pour une prochaine rencontre de le fc
trappes avec l'espoir d'assister cette
fois ci à une victoire de son club
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi reportages et replay à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]